For this first equation, I have an A of negative 2, and a B of positive 3, so my
slope is 2 3rd. For the second equation, the A is positive 3 and the B is
positive 2. So I get a slope of negative 3 halves. The slops are opposite in
sign, and reciprocals of one another, so they must be perpendicular. For the
second pair of lines I know that the first slope is 3 4th and the second slope
is 4 3rd.. These slopes are reciprocals of one another, but they're not opposite
in sign so they can be perpendicular and are not the same so they can be
parallel so they must be neither these lines will just intersect somewhere. For
the last two equations, we can find that their slopes are both negative 2. So
they're the same. They must be parallel, b. Through the last two skills checks,
I hope you've gained a better understanding of what it means for lines to be
perpendicular and parallel.